bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public on est
ensemble pendant 90 minutes des débats
de lectures de l'analyse c'est le
cocktail que je vous propose ce soir
avec nos experts voici le sommaire de ce
16 février du rififi chez les fachos ce
pourrait être le titre d'un roman signé
frédéric da on va vous proposer beaucoup
plus sobrement une guerre fratricide à
l'extrême droite nicolas bay accusée
d'espionner pour le compte d'eric
zemmour est suspendu du rassemblement
national et répliqué en attaquant ses
anciens amis en diffamation récit et
analyses de nos experts juste après ses
titres le dédoublement des classes de cp
et de ce1 dans les rets pl et réseau
d'éducation prioritaire douze élèves au
lieu de 24 mesures phares du quinquennat
macron à l'école est ce que ça marche
reportages et témoignages de notre
rubrique les électeurs ont la parole
tout à l'heure donald trump peut créer
son réseau social et il appelle sa douce
vérité c'est gonflé et c'est surtout un
défi aux médias la traditionnelle qui
l'a vilipendé tout au long de son mandat
aux états unis comme en france ces
discours porte auprès de citoyens qui
font de moins en moins confiance aux
journalistes on analysera ce phénomène
dans notre second débat mais d'abord
l'extrême droite française qui s'offrent
un nouveau psychodrame jonathan des
prières
c'est une nouvelle onde de choc dans les
rangs de marine le pen nicolas bay l'un
des hauts cadres du parti a été démis de
toute fonction exécutive au sein du r n
est déchu de son rôle de porte parole de
la candidate d'extrême droite
le rn l'accusent d' espionnage au profit
de l'équipe zemmour ce qu'il dément
l'accusation est grossière ne
participant à aucune instance de la
direction de campagne comment aurais je
pu connaître et transmettre de
prétendues informations stratégiques
si le r n apporte aucune preuve tangible
le parti accuse nicolas bay de haute
trahison et le soupçonne de vouloir
intentionnellement nuire à leur
candidate on peut pas être dans une cité
dans une dans une forme de sabotage qui
vise à feuilletonner son départ en
essayant d'attendre le plus longtemps
possible dans la campagne présidentielle
pour trouver le bon moment pour partir
pour rejoindre la concurrence en
essayant de faire le plus de mal
possible le départ de nicolas bay était
pressenti depuis des semaines mais les
cadres du parti ont tenté jusqu'au
dernier moment de nier ce qui devenait
inéluctable nicolas bay et a été élu sur
nos listes il est membre je crois du
mouvement depuis très longtemps bien
plus longtemps que moi aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas entendu critiquer marine le pen
pourquoi est-ce qu'il partirait cet
épisode vient une nouvelle fois
fragilisée marine le pen alors que les
défections s'enchaînent depuis des
semaines plusieurs cadres comme gilbert
collard ou encore le sénateur stéphane
ravier sont venues gonfler les rangs
d'eric zemmour à grand renfort de coups
médiatiques
il est clair que ma décision n'est pas
le résultat d'un coup de tête c'est pas
soudain c'est une réflexion depuis
depuis plusieurs mois voire depuis
plusieurs années il était temps et elle
est logique et cohérente ce ralliement
de nicolas bay entérine la guerre
ouverte entre le camp le pen et le camp
et moore tous deux bataillent pour
obtenir leur place au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
et on débat autour de cette actualité et
d'extrême droite avec mes invités la
journaliste claire chartier bonsoir il
ya un revenu jean yves camus bonsoy
histoire et chercheur associé à l'iris
directeur de l'observatoire des
radicalités politique de la fondation
jean jaurès bruno cautrès bonsoir ono
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof avec nous
en duplex erwan lecoeur sociologue
spécialiste de l'extrême droite
chercheur associé du laboratoire pacte
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi et bien
sûr matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir mathieu où on va
évidemment prendre du recul plonger dans
dans l'histoire essayer de comprendre
voilà les lignes de fracture de de cette
famille politique mais peut-être une
première analyse un peu plus
conjoncturelle on va dire que l'artiste
sur la stratégie du rassemblement
national est ce que vous diriez qu'ils
ont tout simplement pris les devants
pour ne pas subir un énième ralliement à
eric zemmour
je pense que ça reflète quand même un
certain énervement à mon avis là ça mais
alors c'est plutôt zemmour eric zemmour
qui a une bonne stratégie parce qu'il
met en scène tous ces arguments tout ça
est très bien préparée il ya le terme de
siphonner l électeur leu leu leu leu r
and tout ça est quand même assez assez
pensé et finalement ça perturbe la
stratégie de marine le pen qui jusque là
joué tactiquement plutôt ou très bien
face à à l'offensive zemmour en restant
calme elle avait même elle était même
resté tellement calme qu'à un moment
elle a finit quand même par se dire faut
que je vous souhaitons donc là elle
emploie un registre qui est quand même
un registre au dessus elles parlent
d'eux-mêmes à semble-t-il à être oui
mais le prendre aussi bien ensemble en
fait une certaine fébrilité même si neuf
départs finalement ce n'est pas non plus
aussi tousser pas l'hémorragie dont
parlait régler moore mais je pense que
là moment je la sens plus en difficulté
plutôt que tactiquement rien alors
l'accusation d'espionnage bon on verra
et pas forcément facile a approuvé
nicolas d nicolas bézy qui va porter
plainte en diffamation je pas sûr que la
justice s'en saisira un jour jean yves
camus
mais en tout cas ça se déroule devant un
tribunal qui est notre affaire que le
tribunal médiatique sur dans ce tribunal
la key qui remporte le match ce soir
d'après vous aux personnes parce qu'elle
a une façon la vérité c'est que les
enquêtes d'opinion donnent aujourd'hui
trois prétendants pour l'accès au second
tour dans la marge d'erreur des sondages
donc ça ne se résume pas à un match
zemmour le pen c'est un match et une
triangulaire les zemmour et crise le pen
premier constat second constat je suis
pas sûr qu'on ne soit pas un petit peu
en train de surévaluer le match pourquoi
parce que finalement alors neuf départs
il y en a en fait plus quand on regarde
vraiment au plan local les ancien
secrétaire de circonscription les
anciens secrétaires départementaux et
pour les connaître ces gens là il faut
être militants encartés si vous êtes
électeur et le ratio entre les 10
millions d'électeurs parfois et les
quelques dizaines de milliers de
militants est quand même faible pour les
militants à vous les connaissez pas donc
vous connaissez effectivement oui des
gens qui souvent d'ailleurs donc pas
passer très très longtemps au
rassemblement national sur une rivière
par exemple vous connaissez nicolas b
parce que oui depuis plusieurs années
effectivement on fait un petit peu le
match nicolas bay c'est une ligne marine
le pen c'est une autre ligne est-ce que
ça détermine votre vote j'en suis
absolument pas sûr donc ce que je
constate c'est qu'aujourd'hui non je
constate deux choses d'abord
historiquement au fn slash rassemblement
national ceux qui partent ou toujours
temps toujours oubliettes la première
scission non me souviens date de 1982 le
parti nationaliste français qui existe
toujours je pense qu'ils sont 50 le mnr
bah oui le mnr existe toujours c'était
bruno mais ça c'est bruno mégret le
parti de bruno mégret existe toujours on
a sorti certains médias ont sorti bruno
mégret je n'ose pas dire du formol mais
lui ont donné une petite une petite
bouffée d'oxygène médiatique fa le mnr
aujourd'hui c'est aussi 50 personnes
donc marine le pen maintien seconde
observation un socle un socle solide que
rien pour l'instant n'a pu entamer alors
ça ne donne pas la présidence de la
république m mais les enquêtes d'opinion
lui donne quand même entre 45 et 48 44
et 45 % des intentions de vote
l'excellent ou second tour ouais et
parce qu'on revient cette triangulaire
dont vous parliez hier en déplacement a
été à villers cotterêts la candidate du
rassemblement national elle parle de
nicolas bay sans le nommer elle dit
j'appelle ça la stratégie de la limace
non seulement parce que la limace est
lente mais aussi parce qu'elle est
poisseux on pourrait parler d' attaques
sur le physique on a aussi entendu
laurent jacot a dit le porte parole un
porte parole de marine le pen dire qu'il
fallait secouer l'arbre pour que les
fruits pourris tombe alors bruno cautrès
ya enfin les la violence des mots en
politique c'est pas l'apanage du
rassemblement national sk une sémantique
quand même de l'extrême droite dans un
dossier comme celui là je suis pas sûr
qu'une sémantique l'extrême droite
particulière à la scission quand il ya
des scissions dans des mouvements
politiques c'est des meurtres entre amis
aux fins des gens qui se connaissent par
coeur depuis des décennies parfois et on
sait que c'est un contexte idéal pour
que les poubelles sorte on va dire à ce
moment là donc on va sans aucun doute
découvrir ou en temps de parler
effectivement un peu des poubelles qui
sortent donc c'est un grand classique
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que le
registre de vocabulaire qui est employé
pour stigmatiser cette trahison c'est un
vocabulaire qui est tous un peu
anxiogène ça fait quand même passer un
message suis d'accord avec jean yves
camus a je pense que ça ne modifie pas
fondamentalement les données de
l'équation compliqué de l'accès au
deuxième tour mais c'est vrai que ça
fait passer un message qui est un
message de mots un peu anxiogène de
trahisons coups d'état le putsch disait
jean marie le pen à l'époque du du mnr
donc on voit aussi enregistré évoque
toujours quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre un peu delà de la guerre des
couteaux qui sont plantés dans quelque
chose qui n'est pas un message
extrêmement positif à un moment donné où
marine le pen a fait tellement d'efforts
pour essayer de crédibiliser sa stature
présidentielle de montrer qu'elle avait
qu'elle avait changé qu'elle incarne et
maintenant quelque chose qui est l unité
du pays ce ce point qui lui faisait
tellement défaut en 2000 17 et donc là
ça l'a ramène un petit peu en arrière
vers un vocabulaire des sujets et on va
dire une communication qui semble un peu
daté pour l
one le coeur si on fait un focus sur
nicolas vais peut-être son histoire il
n'a jamais vraiment fait ce que vous
direz qu'il a jamais vraiment fait
partie de l'histoire de la vous partie
de la famille au sein du fn cela c'est
rennes pour reprendre l'expression de
jean yves camus il est entré dans la
famille assez récemment de napa après
2007 et très concrètement comme le
disait jean yves camus l'extrême droite
nous a habitués à ces histoires de je
dirais de dissension très forte il a
cité certaines des grandes scission
qu'avait connu le front national
d'entendre celui du père et déjà une
collab et faisait partie des mégrétistes
c'est des gens partis avec bruno mégret
et qui a fait les campagnes contre
marine le pen qui l'a accusé d'être là
tanguy de la politique puisqu'elle
restait chez son père à saint cloud qui
l'a accusé de tous les maux possibles et
imaginables avant de revenir comme le
disait jean yves camus parce que word du
front national il n'y avait plus rien à
l'extrême droite megrahi avait échoué
les précédents avaient échoué tous tous
ceux qui avaient voulu renverser la
maison le pen avait échoué là ce à quoi
on assiste aujourd'hui c'est une sorte
de retour du mégalithisme sur le fond de
la ligne politique à savoir une droite
et une extrême droite qui ferait une
alliance pour peser une trentaine de
pour cent et d'une certaine façon une
partie de la france du front national
une partie de ce qui était l air et au
milieu un zemmour mais cette fois
zemmour alias anciennement maigret
toujours conseillé par monsieur jean
yves le gallou un donc le club de
l'horloge de la nouvelle droite des
années 70 et 80 c'est la même stratégie
sauf qu'aujourd'hui il ya un grand
groupe médiatique derrière le groupe
bolloré il ya les médias qui adore cette
histoire qui nous raconte cette saga
avec une bague g départ toutes les
semaines et que marine le pen après
quelques semaines comme ça a été dit à
ne pas réagir a essayé de se
présidentialiser d'être celle qui était
au dessus de tout ça aujourd'hui a
décidé de devancer l'appel de dire mais
en fait tous ceux qui vont partir je
vais les mettre dehors et pas su dire je
vais arrêter de se dire je vais
reprendre l'initiative elle met nicolas
bideau alors elle dit qu'il a trahi qui
la trompe et que c'est un félon le terme
est exactement le même que bruno mégret
en 98 pour jean marie le pen est elle va
reprendre l'initiative de ce point de
vue politiquement comme ça a été dit ça
ne change pas grand chose je dis que je
dirais que eric zemmour n'a pas élargi
son électorat du tout d'un seul électeur
mais médiatiquement ça ça remet en scène
une saga qui est celle selon laquelle
eric zemmour rallierait à lui on ne sait
pas très bien ce qu'il promet d'ailleurs
aux gens qu'ils rallient des places aux
législatives de l'argent ne sait pas
très bien en tout cas ils rallierait à
lui des gens qui n'avaient plus grand
chose à faire aux côtés de marine le pen
on pense à monsieur collard à marion
maréchal ou à d'autres qui avaient
plutôt été dans l'échec ces dernières
années et qui la connaissent un
renouveau politique avec aux côtés de
bruno mégret qui est beaucoup plus
médiatique que politique comme ça a été
dit ça veut dire que ça veut pas être
idéologique tout simplement ce
ralliement en longueur c'est idéologique
mais si vous voulez des trains
traditionnellement l'extrême droite
idéologiquement il ya au moins douze
stands donc si vous voulez il pourrait y
avoir d'autres personnes qui partirait
pour de toutes autres considérations des
monarchistes des néonazis des gens qui
sont des révolutionnaires des
nationalistes intégraux des néo païens
ou des catholiques traditionalistes
on n'entend plus parler d'un certain
bruno gollnisch pourtant il était chez
les cathos tradi ou c'est pas seulement
idéologique c'est toujours aussi le fait
que marine le pen en effet d'une dans
une certaine mesure en termes de
management a très mal géré son parti ces
dix dernières années elle a donné
beaucoup d'argent à ses plus proches et
elle a fait partie où elle a mis sur le
côté tout ce qui me convenait pas trop
parce qu'elle était la seule à offrir
une perspective dans ce camp politique
et donc elle a assez mal manager elle a
perdu les dernières municipales elle a
perdu énormément d'élus elle a perdu au
régional beaucoup d'élus beaucoup sont
fâchés sont un peu attristé beaucoup
partent et sans trop rien dire et là
d'un seul coup ils ont la possibilité de
partir en disant ça y est je vais au
secours de la victoire d'un certain eric
zemmour donc c'est un peu cela qui a
changé mais pour la vente allemand je le
répète en termes stratégiques et
politiques l'électorat de eric zemmour
n'est pas rassuré pour autant marine le
pen ne perd pas un des pans entiers sur
l'électorat puisqu'il est beaucoup plus
populistes et beaucoup moins droitier
néanmoins ça raconte une histoire
médiatique qui n'est pas beau pour
marine le pen enfin dernière chose on
voit bien que madame pécresse a elle
aussi beaucoup de difficultés puisque
par exemple mais ce sarkozy ne la
soutient pas tant qu' on aurait pu
l'imaginer et donc eric zemmour d'une
certaine façon embête les deux camps
traditionnels celui la droite celui
d'extrême droite c'est bel et bien une
idée que maigret avait développé celle
de la nouvelle droite et du club de
l'horloge veulent droite où l'union des
droites on y reviendra évidemment dans
dans ce débat mathieu peut-être un mou
de nicolas bay qu'est ce qui pesé au
sein de et rennes il était dans
l'opposition on va dire à marine le pen
depuis son retour en 2007
ce qui s'appelait à l'époque le front
national dit il et il a été quand même
quelques inquiète déjà les fédérations
c'est quelqu'un qui a été secrétaire
général du front national c'est
quelqu'un qui siégeait au bureau
exécutif jusqu'à la semaine des
relations d'espionnage elle peut
accusations d'espionnage
elles pourraient le point en tout cas
les ralliements ils sont intéressants si
vous êtes un vrai porte étendard si vous
êtes une figure connue c'est pas le cas
de nicolas bay personne ne connaît
nicholas bray dans le grand public dans
chez les électeurs par les gens qui le
connaissent en normandie ou alors c'est
un autre intérêt c'est quand ils
arrivent avec des secrets de fabrique et
dans ses cartons peut-être la stratégie
de marine le pen là c'est sûr qu'il a
assisté à des discussions donc est ce
qui fera une muraille de chine et une en
fera profiter à eric zemmour je pense ça
serait bien naïf de le croire évidemment
qu'ils passent ils passent à l'ennemi
avec avec la stratégie en tout cas de
campagne à laquelle il a participé
jusqu'à maintenant cette suspension
suspension par un bond de nicolas bay on
peut aussi accéder pour la candidate et
rennes une façon de contrer ce qu'elle
appelle la stratégie du salami comme un
saucisson qu'on découpe une défection
par par semaine elle parlait des
trahisons c'était le par exemple elle en
a parlé plusieurs fois mais on a choisi
le 5 février dernier en meeting à reims
on écoute
on est les embuscades ni les manoeuvres
je n'ai comme boussole que l'intérêt
supérieur de notre pays et de notre
peuple la france nous attend
quant à calmer vous pouvez nous
rejoindre parce qu'on va analyser un cas
emblématique bonsoir contart en sorte
rendu ses services de stéphane ravier
anglais m pourquoi parce que c'était le
seul sénateur du rassemblement national
voilà l'annoncent planait depuis
plusieurs jours il l'a fait ce dimanche
ce seul effectivement sénateurs et
rennes historiquement très proche de
jean-marie le pen il a annoncé sa
décision de rejoindre les rangs de
l'ancien polémiste eric zemmour écoutez
le
j'avais des idées des convictions et je
lisais toujours et ce que je constate
c'est qu'elles ne sont plus portés par
marine le pen lesquels sont portés par
eric zemmour je vais donc soutenir là
maintenant tout de suite eric zemmour
dans cette campagne présidentielle quand
je suis convaincu qu'il est lui le vrai
rassembleur voilà une annonce que l'on
avait vu venir car récemment une proche
de stéphane ravier avait parrainé pour
la présidentielle eric zemmour sophie
gresh élus du conseil municipal avait
immédiatement été sanctionné par le
parti et depuis la proximité de l'élu
marseillais avec le polémiste agacé en
interne stéphane ravier jeudi dernier
avait réuni ses partisans s'étaient
devant sa permanence on avait vu ces
images grâce à la provence et dans une
ambiance ce très tendu 1 l'ancien maire
du secteur du 7e secteur de marseille il
avait annoncé à ses troupes qu'il
quittait à ce moment là les instances
nationales du parti lançant au passage
son mouvement marseille d'abord
qu'est-ce qui explique ces brouilles
entre stéphane ravier et marine le pen
alors la brouille thomas elle rentre
vraiment à l'été dernier au lendemain
des élections régionales et
départementales et stéphane ravier se
montrent très critiques sur la stratégie
de marine le pen avec en plus un
rassemblement national qui fait de
mauvais scores à ce moment là puisqu'il
était donné gagnant dans certaines
régions et il pâtit effectivement de
mauvais score et on l'avait rencontré à
sont là avec j'attends du président au
lendemain du second tour et écoutez le
puis peut-être que l'on doit réfléchir
jour son mouvement national sur notre
façon d'aborder ces élections il faut
avoir l'honnêteté la sincérité
d'évoquer les raisons extérieures et des
raisons étaient des raisons internes
donc ça c'était en juin dernier ensuite
à l'automne on avait vu cette visite
d'eric zemmour à marseille cette visite
assez chaotique et les deux cas sont là
qui s'affichent ensemble ravier et
zemmour alors à ce moment là et bien
pour le candidat zemmouri fin qui n'est
pas encore candidat il s'agit d'une
juste une visite de terrain ravier
prends vraiment beaucoup de précautions
on lui a posé la question sur le pulse
le studio depuis x 1 sur le plateau le 3
décembre et il nous parle à ce moment là
d'une simple partie de pétanque écoutez
à cet échange avait lancé un défi un
parisien supporters du psg qui lance un
défi à la pétanque un marseillais
supporters de l'om à marseille
comprendrait bien je pourrais pas rester
comme ça dit quelque chose je savais
qu'il y avait une portée politique à la
venue d'eric zemmour à ce moment là il
n'était pas encore candidat s'est fait
désormais bon se douter qu'il le serait
mais moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent au deuxième tour et qui j'allais
dire déjà près par le rassemblement des
électeurs voilà donc c'était le 3
décembre et on l'entend à ce qu'il dit
est cette possibilité d'une union entre
les deux camps d'extrême droite une idée
aussi que prône nicolas bay est il que
refuse totalement marine le pen cas
merci quentin pour ses explications jean
yves camus 7 cette question de l'union
des droites effectivement vous ne l'avez
dit c'est pas c'est pas nouveau si on
essaie de se projeter au soir du premier
tour de cette présidentielle qu'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer est ce que on va
imaginer que ces coûts soit oubliée pour
que les deux camps le pen et moors se
rapprochent qu'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer moi je me projette pas après
l'immédiatement après le premier tour en
vue du second mais après le second dans
la reconfiguration tout le monde
souhaite en vue des échéances
ultérieures qu'elle soit législatives où
la prochaine présidentielle parce que
bon on admettant que malgré les nombreux
oiseaux qui volent et la sinistre oui
abbès marseillaise convient d'entendre
on va vous en admettant que malgré ça
les électeurs de marine le pen et ce2
d'eric zemmour réussissent à se reporter
sur sur le mieux placé ça fait pas une
victoire ça fait pas une victoire le
grand gagnant pour l'instant dans les
sondages c'est emmanuel macron et puis
par ailleurs pour que cette victoire se
concrétise à l'heure à la rigueur il
faudrait que ce soit une union de toutes
les droites de toutes les droites y
compris éventuellement dans une
configuration où valérie pécresse serait
là la challenger de d'emmanuel macron et
où un des deux candidats ce ne sera pas
marine le pen dirait et goûter pour
éviter le péril d'un second quinquennat
aller contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
mais j'appelle à voter par valérie
pécresse vous imaginez le cadeau
empoisonné
et les possibilités de reconfiguration
que sa défense après parce que tout ça
se passait en fait après le second tour
le la réalité tout ça c'est quand même
moi j'ai tendance à penser que le choix
des électeurs qui se portent pour
l'instant sur marine le pen il est assez
constant et que ce genre de choses lors
leur passe un peu au dessus de la tête
parce qu'au fond ce qu'ils voient à eux
c'est que marine le pen n'est pas
monothématique certains diraient
monomanie à qu'elle parle de l'emploi
et laisse que je ce que je dis c'est
qu'eric zemmour cdc ce qu'il réussit
actuellement est déjà considérable parce
qu'il sort un petit peu nulle part ils
étaient 14 15% c'est déjà considérable
et cela pèsera sur l'avenir mais moi je
voudrais le long tendre sur les mesures
qu'il prendra lorsqu'il sera en
responsabilité partant du constat que le
grand emplacement et non pas quelque
chose qui peut être venir comme le dit
valérie pécresse mais une réalité
aujourd'hui est bien qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour le renverser ce remplacement
pour revenir au peuple français d'avant
ou qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'il fait mise
à part la remise gracieuse guivre mais
quelque chose de parfaitement improbable
est impossible comment va-t-il délivrer
la réalité c'est qu'il ne le peut pas
d'ailleurs il ne le dit pas
walker je viens vers vous parce que vous
devez nous quitter dans quelques minutes
une dernière question est ce que vous
pensez qu on surévalue le poids de
l'électorat zemmour dans l'opinion
française aujourd'hui
oui sociologiquement le poids
l'électorat zemmour n'est pas très
important et même je dirais les valeurs
des français tendent à prouver que celle
d'eric zemmour sont de moins en moins
partagée donc il ya bel et bien un effet
politique à l'effet médiatique en effet
de loupe dirons-nous de cette campagne
depuis six mois eric zemmour halim la
campagne il est donc présent un peu
partout certains chercheurs ont démontré
d'ailleurs que la droite et l'extrême
droite était extrêmement présente dans
l'ensemble des médias l'arrivée
d'internet aussi à modifier profondément
le champ politique et le champ
médiatique ça ce sont deux effets non
négligeables qui forment le paradoxe
français les français sont de plus en
plus ouverts à skis et solidarités
écologie environnement et égalité et
votre aide de plus en plus pour eric
zemmour arrive le pen est à droite c'est
un paradoxe il faut l'explicité de façon
sociologique donc ça n'empêche pas que
l'électorat d'eric zemmour lui ne me ce
n'est pas modifier fondamentalement en
termes d' inscrire ses minimes c'est
très très peu de gens par contre en
terme de mobilisation chez ces gens qui
sont plutôt âgés plutôt des hommes
plutôt très à droite et plutôt bourgeois
il se mobilise énormément
contrairement aux jeunes qui se
mobilisent et qui se démobilisent de
plus en plus donc là on a un lectorat
qui est pas très nombreux en nombre mais
qui est très nombreux en vote ça c'est
la première chose et puis je dirai juste
qu'il ya un autre phénomène c'est que
zemmour démontre le phénomène zemmour
démontre comme l'avait fait un peu
donald trump aux états unis que d'abord
il y as sur internet des choses qui sont
en train de se jouer qui peuvent
provoquer des accidents politique c'est
un premier élément qui doit en effet si
l'une ou l'autre de zemmour lebel était
au second tour il pourrait y avoir des
ralliements sur cette base du tout vers
la crise et où vers le néant un peu
comme en effet dans d'autres pays sa
puce provoquer et puis dernière chose si
eric zemmour peut éventuellement
envisager de barrer la route du deuxième
tour à marine le pen si jamais marine le
pen au second tour là je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qui a été dit il
ya une nouveauté c'est que une partie de
l'électorat de marine le pen ne votaient
pas au premier tour considérant qu'elle
n'était pas assez sur l'extrême droite
soit c'est aussi soit cela aura cette
fois voté au premier tour et on sait
bien que dans la carrière sociologiques
politiques des électeurs le fait de
voter au premier tour en juin votez plus
tôt au deuxième tour et là il ya un
premier accident politique c'est que la
possibilité pour marine le pen
d'aggloméré les ad électorat qui n'était
pas tout à fait convaincu au premier
tour par elle est plus grande et puis
deuxième accident politique c'est le
fait qu'une grande partie de la gauche
étant donné que monsieur maquereau à la
nécessité d'aller chercher de plus en
plus à droite pourrait se dire déçu de
ne pas être au second tour de ne pas y
arriver ou dans le parti de la gauche
donc cette fois contrairement à 2017 ne
viendrait pas sauver le candidat macro
et alors là on aurait un double accident
politique qui pourrait provoquer une
crise merci merci erwan lecoeur pour
pour ses explications c'était prévu que
vous partiez avant 18 ans 25 qui les 24
et 30 secondes merci beaucoup auraient
goûté eric zemmour on a eu marine le pen
quand je perds ma voix il ya quelques
instants eric zemmour justement sur
cette idée rêve je ne sais pas quel
terme employer d'union des doigtés
règlement c'était à cannes le 22 dans 22
janvier
c'est l'appel à abolir ce fameux et
funes cordon sanitaire supprimons entre
nous les frontières pitiot virtuel nous
sommes d'accord sur l'essentiel à vous
avoue électeurs du front national qui
n'en pouvait plus de perdre avoue
électeurs les républicains qui n'en
pouvait plus de voir vos dirigeants
trahir vos idées unissons nos forces
claire chartier est ce que ça pèse est
ce ce discours qui est effectivement on
l'a dit depuis tout à l'heure est un
discours porté par un certain nombre de
deux voies
à l'extrême moratois la droite de la
droite est ce que il est plus fort
aujourd'hui ça on n'est plus dans la
configuration de bruno mégret en 98
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
discours qui a déjà traversé en face est
une idée qui a évidemment déjà traversé
le fn qui d'ailleurs si on remonte
c'était aussi une idée que l'on trouvait
dans les années 30 dans cette extrême
droite l'a donc là on a tout un
environnement qui est propice à cela
aussi parce qu'on a une société quand
même très destructeur est restée très
anomique une certaine manière est donc
tout les accidents ou pas en tout cas
toutes les tous les scenarii sont
possibles d'une certaine manière entre
l'abstention ou voter pour un candidat
antisystème et cetera donc effectivement
des alliances peuvent se se produire moi
ce qui me semble aussi intéressant dans
ce que dans cet affrontement là c'est
que je trouve que ça illustre tout à
fait la particularité de l'extrême
droite française qui quand même une des
plus anciennes en europe et entre une
extrême droite
anti dès 1789 vraiment qui rêvent d'une
dune france multi fiez donc on retrouve
en fait quand on tire le fil on pourrait
tirer le fil jusqu'à 0 aujourd'hui et
puis une autre droite plus récente mais
enfin toutes proportions gardées de la
qui date de la fin du 19ème celle là une
autre tradition en fait d extrême droite
qui est qui était incarnée par le
général boulanger qui était beaucoup
plus populiste proche du peuple qui ne
visait pas d'ailleurs à renverser qui
voulait pas le retour de la monarchie
dont il n'avait pas du tout ce
référentiel là et là qui nous ramène
quand même assez pour revenir sur les
électorats différents à une marine le
pen 13 sociale et ce qui me semble
vraiment distinguer les deux de fait les
deux électorats c'est quand même ces
questions là à quoi sert qu'on a d'un
côté un eric zemmour qui nous renvoie à
d'ailleurs une certaine image assez
élitiste aussi de la france ils parlent
ils envoient des concepts la nation ça
reste quand même un conseil qui
s'adresse à un électorat qui n'est assez
cultivé classe supérieure on sait la
difficulté qu'il a ramené précisément
vers lui les classes populaires et donc
une marine le pen qui elle certes elles
mêmes marqueurs que lui sur
l'immigration mais qui en revanche
assiste au bout coup sûr pouvoir d'achat
la retraite à 60 ans c'est donc dans la
confrontation aujourd'hui ce qui me
semble intéressant c'est que sar fait ça
et surtout je pense qu'eric zemmour est
venu en fait au bon moment c'est à dire
que cette droite marine le pen elle a
finalement duré assez peu de temps ce
qui sait conserver c'est cette tradition
plus anciennes il ya eu un réarmement
l'évoqué tout à l'heure avec la nouvelle
droite à partir des années 70 80 les
armements biologique qui c'est noté très
nettement ces dernières années par des
travaux des productions intellectuelles
des figures qui se sont imposés dès
publication des journaux maintenant une
télévision tous nous travaille en fait
conceptuel de cette extrême droite la
halle a été élaboré donc en fait d'une
certaine manière il ne manquait plus
qu'un personnage le personnage ne venait
pas et puis finalement ce c'est eric
zemmour est bien peu à peu il s'affirme
et puis on l'a poussé parce qu'il a été
entraîné à sa certains me l'ont dit tu
peux y aller et du coup il a fini par y
croire d'ailleurs il il est il est re
fait face est tout à fait l'image aussi
19e siècle du journaliste engagé
extrêmement a failli nous ramène aussi à
ça donc il ya ce référentiel si on
s'appelle rubempré bah voilà donc voyez
le filet les tirer et donc ils ont enfin
sept doigts c'est extrêmement de la a
trouvé son champion est en quelque sorte
la ley le conflit que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est cette extrême droite
un qui ne se retrouvait pas du tout dont
l'extrême droite de marine le pen donc
si elles 120 et si c'est sa crédibilité
naturelle mathieu aux médias je joue
juste une condition qu'un permis ça est
une condition de contexte politique
d'offre politique avec l'atomisation du
champ politique a provoqué l'élection du
maquereau mon père que sans droite et du
gouvernement sans gauche de gouvernement
la reconstruction de la vie politique
française se fait autour de trois pôles
un gros pôle central qu'on peut
qualifier de centre-droit ou le centre
gauche sont là de quel côté il tombe à
chaque élection et puis deux extrêmes
c'est passe pas un hasard si à l'extrême
gauche qui a le vent en poupe entre
guillemets dans le match des
lilliputiens que maire et françois
hollande basse et jean luc mélenchon et
fabien roussel aujourd'hui tous ceux qui
incarnent et plus ou moins la social
démocratie où ce champ là de la gauche
gouvernement est dans les choux et à
droite regardez regardez ce qu'est
devenue la droite parti de gouvernement
qui a quand même
le record de longévité sur l'échelle de
la vème république ils sont à entre 13
et 15% vrai sondage avec valérie
pécresse mais s'arrêter même chose avec
les bertrand bonneau cauterets ce qui ce
qui peut surprendre c'est qu'on a un
eric zemmour qui certes la sur les
derniers sondages on n'a pas le nez sur
les ondes à jour après jour parce
qu'effectivement si on est dans la marge
d'erreur entre les trois candidats des
droites on va dire on voit à peu près ce
que les places et 2 3 4 4 3 2 en
fonction des jours et des instituts mais
en revanche si on regarde le second tour
eric zemmour il est là il est à 65 35
dans tous les sondages depuis des
semaines et des semaines donc pourquoi
continuer de dire qu'on va voter pour
lui au 1er tour alors qu'on est sûr
qu'il sera qui sera jamais vainqueur au
second je crois qu'on ne peut comprendre
la rationalité des différents acteurs à
la fois ceux des acteurs politiques qui
peuvent quitter le rassemblement
national une partie des électeurs que si
on prend en compte ce que disait jean
yves camus tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'une bonne partie de tous ces acteurs
a déjà intégré la presse présidentielle
et c'est là où tout s'éclaire au fond
tant à gauche qu'à droite le tableau qui
apparaît tellement confus aujourd'hui
c'est clair d'un seul coup magnien assez
assez importante parce que c'est bien de
la recomposition dont il dont il s'agit
effectivement toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion montrent aujourd'hui si eric
zemmour se qualifier pour le deuxième
tour il serait écrasé par emmanuel
macron
que marine le pen ferait meilleure
figure elle n'est pas en position de
gagner mais aimerait bien meilleure
figure de style on pourrait dire qu'il
est plus rationnelle pour ce camp
politique de propulser marine le pen
pour avec un meilleur score au premier
tour le candidat qui fait la meilleure
bonne figure au 2e tour pour essayer
aussi
d'incarner qu'à la prochaine élection
s'est rapproché tellement près du
pouvoir en 2022 qu'en 2027 ça va le
faire bon donc mariés devraient soutenir
voilà mais hélas on est dans une autre
rationalité qu'est la rationalité où
tout le monde déjà intégré qu'il est
peut-être très difficile de battre
emmanuel macron que les paramètres qu'il
faut réunir pour battre emmanuel macron
sont tout sauf facile à réunir tous
ensemble ça peut arriver bien sûr mais
ils sont quand même très difficile à
réunir dans tout le monde ce projet déjà
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand emmanuel
macron si emmanuel macron errer et c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là on voit que tout
c'est clair on voit que il ya une partie
de ce champ politique de l'extrême
droite qui effectivement rêve de cette
recomposition et qui va buter sur
effectivement tous les obstacles dont on
vient de parler
qui et les conflits d'intérêts entre des
groupes sociaux qui soutiennent ces
différentes candidatures qui sont
fondamentalement divergent tout le monde
ne souhaite pas
au fond une redistribution des richesses
qui va des plus riches vers les plus
démunis tout le monde ne souhaite pas
dans ceux dans ce secteur de l'électro
de l'électorat et on voit que sur les
questions socio-économiques la place de
l'état à la place de l'état providence
il ya beaucoup de différenciation entre
ce que raconte eric zemmour est ce que
raconte marine le pen donc cette
recomposition que certains espèrent et
rêvent peut-être au lendemain sera tout
sauf hessel et cette recomposition on
l'a bien compris et on va y revenir avec
vous jean yves camus elle est vraiment
dans ce triangle des des droites et
d'ailleurs des figures du traître on n'a
pas fini d'en parler mais elle est aussi
bien que la politique en quelque sorte
même un classique de la vie politique
quand on fait une carrière publique est
rare qu'on nous inculque pas et nous
aurons une fois leur parcours d'avoir le
travail d'une personne de voir triaud
deux parties d'avoir trahi vos vidéos
vos engagements envoient eux mêmes les
électeurs et puis les mêmes des orfèvres
en la matière qu'on fait à peu près tout
ça à la fois je pensais à jacques chirac
évidemment on t'en souviens pour nos
plus jeunes téléspectateurs leçons de
cette première belle trahison en 1974 où
il travaille chaban delmas le goal is au
bénéfice de giscard en publiant son
fameux appel des 43 alors j'ai regardé
la mena parce que je m'en souvenais plus
c'est le 13 avril trois semaines avant
le premier tour comme ça c'est de la
très très belle trahison jusqu'à arrêter
lui et le prix de cette trahison baisse
et matignon dont chirac que claquera la
porte évidemment deux ans plus tard
shirakawa trahira giscard en 1981
l'anecdote est connu mais là encore pour
nos cousins nos plus jeunes
téléspectateurs
chirac fait voter mitterrand sans le
dire bien sûr au second tour et giscard
pour s'en assurer lui-même parce qu'ils
n'en reviens pas pas cinq ou six là une
permanence du rpr à l'époque en
déguisant savoie et demande pour qui
doit voter et on lui dit mais où il faut
voter françois mitterrand donc voilà je
racontais saab est illégal pour
peut-être une affaire de karma aussi je
chirac se fera lui-même trahiront le
rappel par edouard balladur son ami de
trente ans 95 mais il finira quand même
par se faire élire président ça c'est
intéressant les l'image du très très
n'est pas forcément sanctionné par les
électeurs non non non je pense quand on
trahit des personnes deux autres
exemples en novembre 2016 la france
assiste un échange d'amabilités par
écran interposé entre nicolas sarkozy et
emmanuel macron on est dans le dernier
débat d'avant le premier tour de la
primaire de droite et nicolas sarkozy
dénonce l'attitude d' emmanuel macron à
l'égard de françois hollande il dit il a
été soumise et financé maintenant il le
trahit si c'est ça la modernité je
trouve que c'est plutôt classique piqué
au vif et manoirs qu'on répondra deux
jours plus tard la division la vraie
traîtrise s'est quittés il ya vingt ans
celui qui avait fait sa carrière
politique à savoir jacques chirac pour
retrouver monsieur balladur parce qu'il
était plus oppressant d'ouvrir les deux
n'avaient pas tout à fait tort et les
deux ont été élus président donc encore
on n'avait pas forcément autre est bon
même si dans le cas nicolas sarkozy de
purgatoire à droite avec durée quand
même un petit peu plus longtemps passer
d'un candidat à l'autre c'est quand même
monnaie courante l'histoire de
présidentielle l effet de défection
même si ce qu'on se soit à quoi on
assiste quand même je dirais pas
forcément pendant cette campagne même
depuis cinq ans c'est quand même un
gigantesque mercato politique mais comme
on a rarement vu dans l'histoire la vème
république a notamment avec le pouvoir
mc rogne un qui fait venir des figures
de gauche de droite voilà qui débauchent
qu'on dit alors ce sont les méchants ont
dit les débauchages de trahison si on
est positif et que ça vous profiterez
des ralliements met donc l'accompagner
trahison de personnes ici trahir ses
idées oui alors ça ça passe moins que le
travailleur des personnes dans
l'électorat surtout quand vous passez
d'une rive à l'autre je pensais à un
exemple une trahison en février 2007 on
est en février 2007 puis un socialiste
est chargé de chiffrage de ségolène
royal qui traite la porte du parti
socialiste
et voilà et en interroge de ségolène
royal qui dit mais qui connaît monsieur
besson il sera tellement piqué au vif
lui qu'il écrit un livre qu'on ségolène
royal et au premier tour il rejoindra
nicolas sarkozy l'équipe de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy et on soupçonne bien
évidemment d'avoir alimenté l'équipe
sarkozy de tout ce qu'il savait du
programme de ségolène royal à l'époque
je dis ça il a été ministre en cinq ans
eric besson mais après il a jamais
réussi à faire merci monsieur jean yves
camus qu'est ce qui se joue on se
projette je suis d'accord avec vous
après le second tour qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qui se joue c'est peut-être le dépeçage
de l air tout simplement le seul cas de
figure où ça n'arrive pas c'est siri
pécresse la porte et je vais vous dire
oui et l'air n'est pas ma famille
politique mais je trouverais dramatique
pour la démocratie et pour la france qui
n'y pas dans ce pays
une droite conservatrice et libérale
forte qui incarne ce à quoi je pense que
les français nous croient toujours
c'est-à-dire un clivage droite gauche
qui repose en termes d'économies de
choix sociétaux de réelles antinomie
donc d'une certaine manière y a pas de
nouveauté là dedans au milieu des années
80 déjà il existe ou rpr des gens qui
disent mais nous avons un ennemi un
ennemi archétypale et qui pour le coup
exister puisque l'urss ne tombe pas la
fin des années 80 c'est le parti
communiste parti de l'étranger il ya des
ministres communistes au gouvernement le
parti communiste pèse encore quelque
chose unissons-nous nous avons aimons
comme eric zemmour le disais tout à
l'heure des idées en commun cette idée
d'union des droites elle est déjà en
germe dans les années 80 il existe des
gens au rpr qui l'a défendu claude labbé
avait une phrase sur ce thème charles
pasqua l'avait défendu aussi dans cette
dans cette assemblée du sénat il
existait un honorable sénateur de
l'aisne qui s'appelait gilbert 2 qui
était passé au front national parce
qu'il croyait lui aussi qui était à
d'anciens résistants pour le coup n'ont
même pas de la dernière heure que
finalement mort de ce qu'ils avaient en
commun étaient plus importants que ce
qui séparait
mais en réalité je pense véritablement
toute l'histoire des droites radicales
française renvoie à une profonde
antinomie à l'existante de droite qui ne
sont pas réconciliables et ce serait une
erreur très profonde de croire que
simplement pour se débarrasser du
président en place par détestation de
quelqu'un on doit faire la compromission
idéologique consistant à faire front
commun parce que ça on sait toujours
comment ça se termine c'est toujours le
parti le plus fort et c'est pour ça que
jacques chirac avait jamais cédé face à
jean marc il s'était même le terme de
son dernier discours pardon vous arrivez
dernier discours de jacques chirac
président c'est ça ne ne cédez pas à la
tentation de l'extrême droite jacques
chirac avait compris que ça commençait
toujours comme ça le parti le plus fort
du héros le partenaire le plus faible et
finir par la belle et parce que
finalement c'est une petite formation
et puis de jaillir de reniement
idéologie quand grignotage idéologique
vous finissez par vous faire avaler
quand en 1997 dans cinq régions
françaises des présidents de régions où
des candidats à la présidence de la
région sollicitent les suffrages des
conseillers régionaux du front national
ils ne le font pas comme ça c'est pas
bon pour toi c'est sur la base d'un
programme d'un programme et critiques
ont porté notamment en rhône alpes des
concessions majeures ne plus financer
les associations dites multiculturaliste
etc les associations d'aidé aux migrants
promouvoir la culture locale enraciné on
signait quelque chose et monsigna et
jallet a failli signer à et plus
exactement où contre contre toute
l'histoire contre toute la tradition de
la famille mais c'est là où l'on mesure
la formidable accélération de l'histoire
quand même parce qu'il ya encore peu de
temps valérie pécresse claqué la porte
de l air parce qu'elle trouvait l air
trop à droite et il ya encore peu de
temps laurent wauquiez ont le pousser à
démissionner de la présidence de l'air
parce qu'on trouvait une trop à droite
imaginez ont très peu de temps on en
arrive là a aujourd'hui une valérie
pécresse qui fait le boulot d'eric
zemmour eric zemmour n'a même pas à
parler elle même emploi le lexique
d'eric zemmour et on entend à nouveau
par les enseignants stratégiquement
c'était magique
c'est quand même bon je trouve assez
saisissant fait l'accélération de
l'histoire sur ceux sur 7 sur ce bruit
mais l'accélération et l'ailier quand
même un contexte particulier c'est à
dire qu'entre les années 80 et
aujourd'hui il ya quand même la montée
en puissance de l'islam police et sur cd
ya quand même longue liste la longue
litanie des attentats que nous subissons
on va commémorer
malheureusement bientôt le dixième
anniversaire de l'attentât de montauban
et de celui de toulouse et cet ennemi
qui était auparavant le communisme même
beaucoup de gens ne reconnaissent
aujourd'hui non non non pas dans
l'islamisme dans l'islam radical mais
dans les musulmans dans les musulmans et
c'est ici et c'est un risque majeur de
fracture mais il s'est vraiment passé
quelque chose il s'agit pas de nier une
montée en puissance de l'islam politique
il s'agit pas de nier que la plupart de
celles et de ceux qui ont commis des
attentats ou qui ont participé viennent
de notre société sont plus des
combattants qui viennent des montagnes
d'afghanistan pour frapper ici ce sont
des gens d'ici qui frappe ici et ça
c'est de la pure a frappé
il ya aussi quand même le fait je
reviens cette idée là que le pouvoir
macro né à dévitaliser la droite sur le
plan économique la dévitalisées a tenté
de dévitaliser sur les galian no more
darmanin à l'intérieur donc à quand même
enlevé à la droite qui était la droite
conservatrice libérale classique un de
ces chandails substance donc ça va et ce
qui est paradoxal c'est que cette
recomposition à l'extrême droite a fait
exactement de jeu des modèles macron qui
lui de cesse de vouloir composer le pays
le paysage entre le camp des populistes
dit il et des affreux des méchants et
des progressistes qui seraient les gens
bien voilà ça c'est un boulevard pour
lui si jamais ça se passe la conclusion
d'un sac la séquence qui va de la
présidentielle aux législatives est
tellement importante parce qu'au fond
pour les républicains à l'issue de tout
ceci quelle est l'issue pour valérie
pécresse et pour les républicains aux
élections législatives
la grande question stratégique va se
poser est ce qu'il s'agit pour eux au
fond d'eux finira bain de phagocyter
d'une certaine manière le deuxième
mandat d' emmanuel macron s'il est réélu
et au fond de rejouer une sorte de match
rpr udf à l'ancienne au fond de giscard
disait macron en intégrant fortement le
pouvoir en place ou est-ce que à travers
le résultat d'aleri pécresse et des
législatives les républicains peuvent
redresser et dire on est une force
d'opposition peut-être qu'on a pas guina
présentiel mais on est la principale
force d'opposition ils sont à une
croisée des chemins comme rarement ils
auront été merci beaucoup c'était
passionnant merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce
débat qui j'en suis convaincue aura
éclairé nos téléspectateurs par votre
choix vous projeter déjà dans la
recomposition d'après second tour de la
présidentielle notre émission